how do you take that passion being
in your mid-30s i i find that
interesting that you say that it's true
when you're young and you're hungry and
you can be quirky and all these
different things doors open and people
are more forgiving and i think either a
when you're older they get scared or
they get threatened right or a
combination of both right so how do you
even though you have it in that how do
you temper it a little because they get
the stakes get a little tougher they do
they get i mean just the dynamic shifts
because you have done work and you have
you have a track record and they say
okay well
you know some of your movies haven't
done all that well or this or that and i
think you develop a lot more
uh tactics as far as
how you present it and how you go about
doing it and you you be realistic about
it
um
but you still have to be persistent and
but you have to be wiser in how you
leverage yourself i think what you have
when you're when you
in your 30s and you get older is you you
figure out how to leverage what you've
done in the past and leverage
leverage that and and take that
take that anger
away and replace it with leverage of
okay i've done these films they've some
of them done well some of them haven't
and use that to your
strength versus when you're young and
you haven't done anything you're just
like
i need a shot
you know i deserve a shot
well now it's not i'm not saying i
deserve a shot i say i deserve to keep
doing this because of so narrow instead
of saying i deserve this it's now it's
all because of or i can bring this to
the table or
this is going to benefit you in a way i
think as you get older you figure out a
way to
you're not selling yourself you're
you're you're convincing someone else
why they should be involved what they're
going to get out of it
you know it's a win-win
yeah it's a win-win it's like
you have to be a salesman in a way
you know and
sell yourself in the room and and
um
what if someone's not good at that
what if they're just not like that's not
who they are then they better be so
talented they better be so and there's a
lot of very talented people who aren't
good at being in a room and talking and
selling themselves they better be so
talented that their work is just so
incredibly
um unique and rare and great that they
don't need to that they have other
people to do a form i don't fall in that
category my films aren't so great that
they're like oh we're going to hire this
guy you know my films are
they're marginally
well received
movies
that
for the money for the level i'm working
in
are good now when i get i'm still
growing like anything else
you know but there are people out there
who are
so refined and they're so cerebral
they're so talented and they figure
everything out they just they're not
good in a room
and their careers suffer because of it
or you know
i wish there was a formula but there's
not
you